[Musica]
[Applauso]
ogni cosa è figlia del proprio tempo
cambiano gli usi cambiano i costumi
anche quelli da bagno
cambia la tecnologia cambiano gli
oggetti che noi utilizziamo e cambiano
anche le malattie nella terza fotografia
e vedete il quadro clinico del vaiolo
come malattia che nei primi decenni del
novecento ha causato centinaia di
migliaia di milioni scusate di morti in
tutta europa e che oggi è stata
virtualmente debellata grazie un vaccino
questo è il risultato più in generale la
nostra evoluzione evoluzione che grazie
alla tecnologia ci ha permesso di
sconfiggere molte malattie e
parallelamente ha contribuito a crearne
altre l'evoluzione che però analizzata
sia dal punto di vista tecnologico sia
dal punto di vista puramente biologico
non può evitare una cosa il fatto che
dobbiamo morire ma guardate se avete
pagato il biglietto per sentirvi dire da
qualcuno che dovete morire
eppure così quali sono le principali
cause di morte oggi nel mondo
occidentale sono le malattie
cardiovascolari e solo i tumori maligni
io oggi vi parlo ai tumori maligni
perché il mio campo di attività clinica
e di attività di ricerca e perché la
diagnosi di tumore un momento
particolarmente difficile nell'economia
di una singola persona e della famiglia
che gli sta intorno dietro ogni persona
ci appunto una famiglia c'è una storia
più o meno lunga è un problema di cui si
parla poco e questo è intuitive da un
lato anche comprensibile perché noi
siamo tendenzialmente protesi verso la
bellezza e non ci piace parlare di cose
brutte ma dall'altro lato è un qualcosa
che tutti dovremmo conoscere perché i
numeri purtroppo parlano chiaro il
rischio di ammalarsi di cancro durante
la vita è di uno su tre è a rischio di
morire di cancro è di 1 su 5
e questi sono dati che purtroppo troppo
spesso si scoprono al punto nel momento
della diagnosi che il momento critico
specialmente nell'interazione medico
paziente
nel momento in cui sorgono le domande
fabrizio vieni avanti
ciao maurizio ciao ciao cortina
cosa ti è successo fabrizio e io sono
uno su tre spiegaci meglio l'anno scorso
giuseppe mi ha diagnosticato un cancro
al pancreas e ci siamo trovati nel suo
studio per capire cosa fare fabrizio
senti tu fumavi non molto poco da veri
assolutamente no perché maggiore è il
mio conduce di uno stile di vita
particolarmente sregolato non
particolarmente come stai adesso io sto
bene
il cancro mi ha fatto bello perso 30
chili non correvo e voglio correre la
maratona fra non può non più di due tre
mesi
fabrizio perché perché è proprio tu non
lo so sono venuto qui apposta a
chiederlo e questo è quello che io
cercherò di spiegarvi in pochi minuti
cercherò di spiegarvi cos'è il cancro e
cercherò di spiegarvi perché nel cancro
il cancro nasce deriva da alterazioni
del meccanismo di replicazione delle
cellule le cellule sono i mattoncini che
compongono i nostri tessuti e si
replicano a una velocità variabile in
relazione al tipo di tessuto la
replicazione delle cellule avviene
secondo un meccanismo preordinato che si
chiama ciclo cellulare durante la fase
di vera e propria divisione del ciclo
cellulare il nostro materiale genetico
c'è il dna viene equamente ripartito
nelle due cellule figlie è un po
difficile spiegarvi come si replica il
dna immaginate una cerniera una cerniera
che si apre due branche della cerniera
costituiscono i filamenti figli che
vengono riempiti dal da un secondo
affidamento secondo un principio di
complementarietà biochimica delle
molecole ripeto è un meccanismo un po
difficile da capire ma avviene è una
cosa meravigliosa che è stata scoperta
negli anni cinquanta e che permette
appunto di generare due cellule figlie
da una cellula madre
questo meccanismo però come tutto nel
mondo peraltro non è perfetto e molto
spesso molto più spesso di quanto noi
possiamo pensare va incontro a degli
errori questi errori vengono riparati
perché abbiamo dei meccanismi appositi
di riparazione degli errori però quando
questi errori avvengono ripetutamente
nelle porzioni particolari del genoma
che sono deputati al controllo appunto
del ciclo cellulare possono sorgere dei
problemi e le cellule di un dato tessuto
possono acquisire la capacità di
replicarsi in maniera incontrollata a
finalistica acquisendo nel tempo la
capacità di invadere il tessuto di
origine i tessuti circostanti e di
andare anche in ordine distanti
questo è il cancro perché nel cancro
il cancro viene dunque perché si
verificano nel momento di divisione
delle cellule delle cosiddette mutazioni
che il termine tecnico per gli eroi
di cui di cui vi parlavo prima quindi il
cancro viene perché si verifico delle
mutazioni perché rendono le mutazioni
come un po come in astronomia andare
sempre più avanti nella spiegazione di
un fenomeno cena arrivare al concetto di
big band perché è nato l'universo è un
po la domanda che noi ci facciamo perche
non c'e il cancro le mutazioni possono
verificarsi per tre determinati fattori
il primo è la perturbazione della
replicazione della cellula a causa di un
fattore esterno che chiameremo fattore
di rischio
il secondo meccanismo è un meccanismo e
ti pare di tario richiamo la mutazione
dalla mamma dal papa il terzo meccanismo
è una accumulazione casuale di mutazioni
genetiche è il fattore che pesa di più
in questo processo il fattore ereditario
è quello che pesa di meno
gli altri due sono i più interessanti e
cercherò di guidarli brevemente per
capire quale dei due pesa di più è
importante questo concetto perché oggi
tutta la l'informazione ci stressa molto
sulla prevenzione dei tumori sul
controllo dei cosiddetti fattori di
rischio sono quelli cui parlavo prima
che dei fattori ambientali che possono
in qualche maniera interferire col
genoma questioni fattori di rischio più
più comuni quindi l'alimentazione
scorretta specialmente per i tumori del
tratto gastro intestinale fumo di
sigaretta e l'inquinamento ce ne sono
tanti altri un po meno conosciuti ad
esempio il primo la polvere del dei
camini e stato il primo fattore
ambientale che ci ha permesso di
correlare i fattori ambientali stessi
con il cancro in particolare il cancro
del testicolo nel settecento all'asbesto
alcune tossine micotiche la luce luce
del sole i raggi ultravioletti e il
papillomavirus per cui esiste un vaccino
tutti noi pensiamo che il cancro sia in
qualche maniera ha causato da questi
fattori
in realtà non è proprio così perché il
concetto di causa conseguenze piuttosto
difficile da dimostrare in questo
settore è più invece è pregnante
sostenere che un'esposizione prolungata
a questi fattori di rischio possa
aumentare in qualche maniera l'incidenza
dei tumori
e allora quale dove sta la vera causa
qual è il vero primum movens di questo
fenomeno è il fattore c è quindi il
fattore è casuale
e questo piuttosto inquietante i suoi
abbiamo ricercato per cento anni le
cause del cancro e stiamo arrivando alla
concezione che il cancro causato dal
caso questa è una pubblicazione del 2015
su science che è un po sconvolto il
mondo scientifico è un modello
matematico complesso che non tende che
non vi spiego che sostanzialmente
dimostra in maniera molto elegante che
circa il 75 per cento dei tumori è
frutto del puro caso
in particolare il rischio di sviluppare
un tumore durante la vita sarebbe
proporzione al numero di divisioni delle
cellule staminali che sono le cellule
progenitrici e le cellule normali in
ogni e tessuto questo modello è stato
anche criticato come succede in tutte le
nuove scoperte perché non tiene in
particolare considerazione appunto i
fattori ambientali che sono quelli poi
modificabili attraverso gli stili di
vita nel 2017 medesimi autori una
italiano tomasetti lavoro in america
alla johns hopkins hanno allargato il
modello includendo anche i fattori
ambientali
non sto a spiegarvi questa questa
diapositiva mi spiego solo il concetto è
il concetto è piuttosto impressionante
prende il tumore del polmone che il
tumore che più facilmente si riesce a
correlare con un fattore ambientale che
il fumo di sigaretta soltanto il 50 per
cento ai tumori del polmone è
prevenibile attraverso l'astensione dal
fattore di rischio per il cancro del
pancreas che il tumore che io studio
nella mia nella mia attività
questo fenomeno ancora più inquietante
perché circa il 70 80 per cento dei casi
insorge per puro caso
in realtà il modello per quanto possa
essere elegante matematicamente robusto
lo spiega perché l'incidenza di tumori
sia molto variabile in relazione
all'area geografica ma questo è un
argomento che probabilmente verrà e
lucidato nei prossimi anni dunque il
messaggio quale è un messaggio
distruttivo non c'è nulla che noi
possiamo fare perché è tutto deputato al
caso
come possiamo fare noi per prevenire
l'insorgenza del cancro e tutta questa
prevenzione di cui medici vi parlano è
in realtà un bluff assolutamente no il
messaggio non vuole essere un abbandono
del concetto di prevenzione sia primaria
cioè l'eliminazione delle cause
possibili dei tumori o privi prevenzione
secondaria quindi di diagnosi precoce
e questo è un esempio bisogna sottoporsi
ai programmi di screening che sono ma di
dati internazionalmente che sono
disponibili tutto il territorio perché
comunque fanno la loro parte anche se i
programmi di screening purtroppo sono
presenti per un piccolo numero di tumori
perché la biologia della maggior parte
delle oplà xi e è molto complessa oggi
si le frontiere della ricerca stanno
tentando di trovare nel sangue delle
sostanze che possono essere associate ai
tumori in fase molto precoce ma ripeto
questo è un processo molto difficile
perché le vie di trasduzione del segnale
di liberazione le molecole nel sangue e
le fasi precoci malattia sono molto
varie ancora non sono ben comprese anche
se negli ultimi anni sono stati fatti
passi da gigante grazie a macchine come
queste che si chiamano sequenziatori
sequenziatori sono delle macchine che
rompendo il dna in mille frammenti
riescono a decodificarle come una
stampante che scrive un libro è che noi
possiamo leggere in questo modo siamo
stati capaci di decodificare il genoma
di tutte le neoplasie attraverso un
consorzio un consorzio internazionale di
cui il centro in cui lavoro fa parte per
le minute lasi e pancreatiche e questo
rappresenta anche un fondamentale passo
nei confronti di approcci terapeutici
nuovi che possono essere personalizzati
sulla base delle alterazioni genetiche
del singolo paziente
questo ancora non è possibile su base
routinaria non è ancora possibile alla
pratica corrente ma il futuro è quello
che che avverrà tra chissà quanti anni
magari 10 magari 20 magari 30 ma verrà
questa è la risposta alla domanda che io
mi sono posto per voi e spero di avervi
dato un'informazione quanto meno utile
ma c'è un'idea da condividere
e io vorrei sfruttare il modello di
cancerogenesi per allargare un po
l'orizzonte al al concetto più ampio
appunto di scienza e di e di ricerca
scientifica
la scienza è guidata da un vettore di
forze mi piace dire unidirezionale che
ci porta sempre in avanti questo vettore
spinto da dietro in avanti dalla
conoscenza che noi abbiamo e che ci
mettiamo dietro alle spalle che si
accumula sempre di più proiettandoci
fisicamente
quanti dall'altro lato ci richiama
sempre in avanti il vuoto di ciò che noi
non sappiamo
questo implica due concetti fondamentali
il fatto che la conoscenza è necessaria
non si possono generare ipotesi non si
possono generare teorie se non sia a
conoscenza
dall'altro lato bisogna essere consci di
essere ignoranti e questo è
particolarmente triste nel campo in cui
io opero perché nella mia tumori
pancreatici sono più le domande che le
risposte spesso il bisogno di
informazione che le persone hanno porta
a una serie di domande a cui noi non
sappiamo rispondere è una sorta di
pretesa di cura che è sempre più forte
ma spesso e volentieri questo è quello
che noi possiamo dirvi ciò che non siamo
ciò che non vogliamo per per usare
montale meraviglioso è un processo di
evoluzione molto lunga parte da una
presunzione icaro che vuole volare cade
però nel tempo vengono fatti degli studi
degli studi sistematici questa leonardo
da vinci a questi studi anche dopo tanto
tempo portano dei risultati il primo
volo delle macchine che portano in giro
per il mondo 600 persone al centro di
tutto questo processo resta sempre e
comunque
l'uomo l'uomo di vitruvio di leonardo è
un omaggio che leonardo stesso voleva
fare al pensiero classico ai canoni ma
allo stesso tempo è un auto celebrazione
della scientificità della propria arte
la figura umana le proporzioni
matematicamente armoniosamente iscritta
nelle figure perfette del cerchio e del
quadrato il cerchio che rappresenta il
cielo il divino il quadrato che
rappresenta la terra l'uomo sospeso tra
cielo e terra e proteso verso l'ignoto e
proprio per questo che il pensiero
umanistico e il pensiero scientifico
integrati nella ricerca sono l'unico e
il solo strumento che noi oggi abbiamo
per rendere migliori noi stessi i nostri
figli i nostri nipoti e la vita del
mondo che verrà
abc